we need to be wary of authenticity
because some people are really authentic
but [ __ ] awful hello and welcome to
trigonometry I'm Francis Foster I'm
constant in kissing and this is a show
for you if you're bored with people
arguing on the internet over subjects
they know nothing about a trigonometry
we don't pretend to be the experts we
ask the experts are absolutely brilliant
guests this week is a former chief
speechwriter for a prime minister he is
the chief leader writer for The Times
and the author of when they go low we go
hi Philip Collins welcome to change I
see to be here for anyone who doesn't
know young before before we go and I
should say Philip used to speech right
for Tony Blair but that was after the
Iraq war so please don't switch off tell
everybody I mentioned a few biographical
details just tell everybody who you are
how are you where you are what's been
your journey through life
well I the point of that where my career
code took off is when I went to work for
Tony Blair that was a slightly random
event because I'd never written a speech
before in my life
the very first speech I ever wrote was
for Tony Blair I'd written in all kinds
of different formats I'd written novels
I'd written plays I'd written lots of
comedy sketches and I loved writing I'd
also worked in politics and I'd also
worked in television and I'd been an
academic political philosopher so I'd
had all these sorts of random things I
never stuck at anything my mom used to
say and I'll kind of all came together
in political speech writing so the
desire to write and craft arguments
which I got from philosophy came
together with a political interest and
this person this leader who really
wanted to speak I was basically in
sympathy with politically that I didn't
agree with him on everything and it just
all came together and I knew people who
work for Blair from my previous life in
working for Frank field many years
before and they approached me and said
Blair's looking for someone and I
decided I wanted to be the speechwriter
I insisted that I would come but only if
I could write speeches and they said to
me don't do that that's a graveyard job
it's awful
writes all his own speeches he hates
people helping him it's it's terrible
job and I said no that's the thing I
want to do and it was that was the best
decision I ever made because it meant as
a speech writer I had a real job at a
very specific job nobody else wanted my
job which is really important inside
Downing Street and it meant I got to
spend a lot of time with the Prime
Minister because I needed to be here all
the time what he was thinking so it was
a slightly random event even relating it
like that I can't quite remember why I
thought that but I did and and that's
what happened and ever since I left
Downing Street I've carried on writing
speeches for lots of business people and
other politicians too so I've written
hundreds of them
now and I was good I was going to say
what is the way that you craft a speech
how do you do it is it because I've
written for comedians do you do it in
the politicians voice or do you think
right this is what they sort of want to
say and I'm going to do it what I think
how does it work yeah it's very
introduce a sort of mimicry they're sort
of where you've got to be careful that
when I went to work for Blair he was
just going through that period where
it's early period where he didn't use
any verbs you know the new labor yes
marvelous wonderful although I have to
say as a former primary school teacher
who taught English I'm disgusted at the
lack of right so was I so was I and so I
I job was to put verbs it almost it was
to go from these like very short skirt
ale sentences to proper argument so I my
task was to change him a little bit so
whilst you are trying to get his voice
because he want this continuous
character to unfold through time I was
also trying to change him so it's that's
a difficult thing you need to get to
know someone quite well you need to get
a sense of their voice but the same time
you're trying to capture them at their
best at all times so you're trying to
give them the sort of edited highlights
of who they are so whenever I work with
people now I say we want it to sound
like you but you are you're really very
best so let's take all the best things
you've ever said and let's put them all
together and edit out all the rubbish
bits and that will still sound like you
but an elevated heightened form and
that's what I'm trying to do when I'm
when I'm capturing a voice
and what was it like for you coming in
from you obviously said you had worked
in politics but you clearly had a career
though there was much broader than that
and suddenly you're in this place which
is all about the politics 24/7 I imagine
it's intense it's everything is
last-minute what was that like well it
was like that but it also wasn't in the
sense that Blair was very easy to work
for
and the calendar is reasonably fixed so
I knew when the speech was and so I had
these sort of staging posts and I'm just
quite inclined to do things at the last
minute you know that's how I like to
work I like the adrenaline rush of the
deadline and he was like that too nobody
else in the building was they used to go
mad that with the day to go we haven't
really started people starts too early
in my view you just leave it until the
last minute and then eventually the rush
comes that's what I'm doing for my time
for sure I just have this this the
procedure was for every speech about a
week before ten days before the speech
was due we'd have a meeting with a bunch
of the the team to discuss what we might
say and you couldn't do it before there
because politics moves so quickly
anything you did before then would
simply be eradicated and date so you'd
have that meeting you'd come to his
provisional idea of what you might talk
about I would go away and commission
work and research it and talk to the
relevant ministers and square people off
etc I wouldn't write anything at this
point and then with a couple of days to
go with on another meeting or I'd be I
would supposed to present what I was
going to suggest and about an hour
before that meeting I'd hastily
scribbled something down present it
there at that meeting Blair would always
always say oh but I didn't want that I
wanted this wanted that you haven't put
any of this in and that when I was
inexperienced I made the mistake of
saying to him no it's all in there look
at all of that stuff is in there what I
learned to do was to say yes okay
definitely then the next day I'd give
him exactly the same script and he'd say
oh yeah that's much better that's what I
meant are you exaggerating here are you
genuinely a little bit so you change a
couple comments a little bit my I would
I would say I take the criticism I say
yeah absolutely and then I give him the
sense
- same thing the following day and he
would feel there that yeah that's what I
wanted and and at that point we'd get
serious and then it really kicked off on
the morning of every speech where I
would go into Downing Street very early
sort of five or six in the morning and
he would have my scripts which I had
given him and he would go up to his flat
and he'd be sitting there and his
dressing-gown his boxer shorts beautiful
image and I go if he's sitting over in
the corner and he would have my script
and he would be scribbling on it and
he'd win fountain pen he'd write all
over it and then we would cut and paste
his bits and my bits and when I say cut
and paste I don't mean any newfangled
computer terminology I mean literally
cutting with scissors his bits and my
bits and then we take them downstairs to
the place where all the typist sat and
we'd paste them on a piece of paper and
create this collage there was then the
script I would take that away but this
will be back with an hour to go I take
it away and then type through it to
ensure that all the transitions between
his bits and my bits were smooth and
that it made sense as an unfolding
argument and that would then be the
thing which we just about finish in time
to go up on the altar queue now this is
ludicrous waste work a terrible ways to
behave I wouldn't recommend it to
anybody but it sort of worked and was
part of that down to you know the fact
that your stars meshed together quite
nicely and what was it also down to the
fact that boy was and continues to be a
superb orator yeah it was we did mesh we
also I think brought complementary
things because my task was to provide
the body of the argument so most of the
speeches I worked on ended up being his
introduction a political setting was
seen at the beginning which was more or
less in his voice in his his words than
the body of the argument which I would
have right I came to realize that I
shouldn't be Precious about any words as
such there's a real mistake you can make
is to think that no it's got to be those
words if you don't make the arguments in
those words then then I've failed
actually what I wanted to get through
was the correct argument so the main
body of the speech will be mine where
all the facts and the illustrations
would be and then he would usually write
the ending he'd write to kind of
flourish at the end which would be a
political message and that was usually
the
so we ended up with and that that worked
quite nicely because he by the end I he
came to trust me that I would get the
argument right you've got to remember
you got to have a certain humility that
you are writing for him it's not me he's
the Prime Minister not me but he was and
so there are times when you're writing
things that you don't necessarily
entirely believe but you have to make
the best possible argument that he wants
to make not import your own argument
it's important that you recognize as a
fact see I'm glad you brought that up
because at what point as a scriptwriter
can you actually go do you know what I
ver mentally disagree with what this may
be so for instance it's interesting that
you say you came after the Iran war yeah
you know so a lot of people would say
hang on I mean you know there's very
legitimate arguments to say that Blair
is a war criminal yeah
what do you not feel as a speechwriter
slightly morally compromised by
representing his views I think if you if
you do if you get to the point where you
just think I can't do this that's the
point where you have to leave so there's
you have to judge that so I mean I
didn't occur to me on that issue I mean
prior to joining I was I thought the
case we're at war was a poor one and I
wasn't I was a opposed to it however I
never thought that that meant he lied
about it because having knowing what the
the chronology of it was I know that's
not conceivable he couldn't possibly
have lied about it because everybody
thought that they had the weapons the
the error they made and the was that was
the use of that material they
exaggerated I think the the certainty
they felt about it to to uphold an
opinion but I mean that rhetorically is
what you always do you always make the
best possible case you think well I'm
going to do X wrong and why therefore
I'll make the best possible case for X
and that's what they did and I think
probably no culpably and wrongly so I
was always opposed to it but I never
felt it was so clear cut that it meant I
couldn't do it the one speech I worked
on where I really was a long way from
his sensibility was on
identity cards I was much much more
liberal on crime and Home Affairs than
he was he was quite right-wing on all
that stuff
he was very strongly in favor of British
people having identity cards and I
wasn't and I thought well is this a
resigning issue do I care so much that I
have to give up and walk away actually
no I don't care that much it's not a
defining issue of my life and the weird
thing was I wrote probably the best
speech I wrote for him the most forensic
ly tight speech I'd ever did because I
was so accustomed to why this was a
terrible idea
identity cars that I avoided all the
terrible arguments for it and found
quite strong arguments for it and I gave
him something which it was quite unusual
but he really liked it so weirdly that
distance from the argument helped me you
know that is such an interesting point
because one of the things we were kind
of trying to stay away from in this
interview but we talked about a lot is
the culture wars that are happening now
and one of the things seems to be is the
desire to shut down the opposing
argument and of course one of the
greatest weaknesses of that process is
you don't ever learn to understand how
other people think and to present the
counter-argument that's absolutely right
good speeches speeches fail or lots
because people caricature the opposing
argument this happens in politics all
the time where if I were to Gordon Brown
just do this really really badly whereas
if I say if I were to do a speech as a
soft labour spokesman and I took to an
audience which comprises people who were
Labor Act Orion and and other things in
between and I were to say to them you
know the Conservative Party is
deliberately impoverishing the nation
they're deliberately targeting the poor
because they relish the pain of the poor
feel if I'm a conservative voter who in
the audience
I'd think that's not me that's not what
I think actually I don't think that at
all whereas if you were to say instead
that the Conservative Party doesn't give
due priority to the needs of the poor
and in its desire to get the public
finances under control it is doing so at
the cost of the poor that's different
that's not a caricature that's
that might make the conservative Oh to
think mmm no I fear that might be true
and so to be a little bit more generous
to your opponent's it's actually a
really good way of then taking the bond
and in politics you don't get that very
often and I always try to get that into
speeches that you need to name the
opposing argument I give you a really
good historical example Elizabeth the
first Tilbury she is the leader of the
armed forces she's queen is a Spanish
Armada gathered ready to try and invade
and all the Navy they're just think
you're a woman you can't possibly come
out of the Armed Forces it's ridiculous
and she goes there to address them and
instead of pretending that's not what
they think she absolutely names that
argument she says I may have a weak and
feeble body of a woman drive the hearts
and stomach of a king and she goes
straight to the weakness the perceived
weakness of the argument tells them what
they're thinking exactly as they are
thinking it and then turns it around she
wins a standing ovation the idea that we
have of Elizabeth is this formidable
queen dates from that speech from that
moment and if you a name the argument
properly and if I tell you or describe
to you what you're thinking already in
terms which you recognize and you think
yes that's a reasonable of what I think
then I'm in a better position to engage
with you if I take you on because you're
at least the field I've done you the
courtesy of understanding what you saw
what you think rather than if I say
you're an you're an obvious murderer and
a loathsome individual you think
actually I'm curious to get your opinion
on because as you say in politics it
doesn't seem to happen often but in the
last five years I think we've gone way
off the deep end on I mean you had David
Lammy talking about conservatives is
worse than not not just Nazis worse the
Nazis say what you want about Jacob Riis
mark he's got an authentic feel do you
know who that guy is right but we've got
to this point where we don't we're not
even talking about the argument anymore
it's just you not to you this you that
name call isn't it yes insulting and
it's really really bad is we're dialing
out rhetorically 211 and and I mean that
David Lammy speech was really bad I mean
David Lammy is a very interesting
speaker because he's got the biggest
range between his good days bad days of
any politician I've ever seen because
David is capable of being extremely good
really eloquent and really powerful and
really thoughtful he's also capable of
being terrible as that speech indicates
because that is actually ridiculous you
know to describe anybody as you know
worse than that's no other than hostages
they're really not it's a stupid thing
it does it certainly scores no good
because you don't come away thinking got
those Tories yeah they're about to
commit genocide you came all way
thinking David lamby's lost it yeah yeah
so you've got to be careful you've got
to stay within the bounds of
plausibility but I do agree with the
premise of your question which is we are
becoming more raucous we're becoming
less generous less civil and politicians
are contributing to that I mean the
obvious example is Donald Trump in the
States and Nigel Ferrara sort of smaller
version here Trump is the the one who's
really dialing it up I mean I noticed
the first time I saw Trump is every
American president goes to the to
Gettysburg to do a version of Abraham
Lincoln's Gettysburg Address they all do
it the sort of cover version it's a rite
of passage and they all go and they do
exactly the same speech really which is
a paean of praise to the american
republic like lincoln did and it's kind
of moving they're all they're all plea
che is really but it's nice that they do
it because what they're saying is this
is secular liberal democratic government
and we're paying our respects it is a
cemetery after all at the civil war
cemetry and you're literally standing in
front of graves so it's a it's a nice
moment the only to the only present who
didn't do that was kennedy because on
the day he was doing gettysburg to do
the centenary address he had to go down
to dallas instead or important party
business
the next day was shot never came back
and then in the campaign in 2016
Trump went to Gettysburg and where
Abraham Lincoln spoke two minutes 45
seconds the Gettysburg Address Trump
spoke for 45 minutes Lincoln did a
lovely eulogy to government of the
people for the people by the people
Trump called Hillary Clinton a criminal
said American politics was rigged said
the media we're out to get the people
said that the little class was was
corrupt and was rigging everything
against it and it was just a horrendous
speech it would have been awful anywhere
but to do it there in Gettysburg
deliberately was a real indication that
he wasn't to play by the rules
I thought that is a real escalation well
that is something I wanted to ask you
about because you can criticize Donald
Trump for a lot of things but not in
terms of effectiveness he's clearly an
effective orator and a lot of people
have been very snooty about him because
he doesn't speak very clearly he he
doesn't come across as someone who's
conventionally articulate shall we say
but there is no doubt that he's
persuasive oh yeah absolutely yeah
absolutely I mean persuasion comes in
many forms and Annie had chili has
persuasion I mean people talk a lot
about authenticity and it's a very good
example we need to be wary of
authenticity because some people are
really authentic but [ __ ] awful Trump
is extremely authentic that is what he's
like he's really good at it he has a
character and the word characters are
important in persuasion through speeches
and you think of the dual meaning of
character it character is something that
we play so you when you're speaking on a
podium it's not a natural event to speak
um uninterrupted for half an hour you
have to play yourself you have to get
into character you know it's not that
unlike going on the stage as a sort of
supercharged version of yourself if
you're doing as well comic routine or
some kind of cabaret you are you are
yourself but you're not like that all
the time but there's a connection
between the two and being a rhetorician
is like that but character is also
something that you have you know we have
character and so you're displaying that
sense of character they would and that's
where we get the idea or authenticity
from and Trump is really good at this
and they go back to Aristotle which is
the one the only trades in which you can
get comedy being another but you can go
right back to the classics and the the
analysis of how they do it is the same
today as it was then and rhetoric is
like this and Aristotle says were three
things there's character which he calls
ethos
there's pathos which means emotion and
then there's logo smooth means
rational argument and someone like Trump
communicates so much through character
you know so much about him just from the
way he is you know businesses will be
brand and in rhetoric it's character and
he uses emotional arguments all the time
and Aristotle's view which I'm sure is
right is that character and emotion are
far more effective in persuasion than
rational argument look at the European
referendum debate and the in 2016 one
side leave full of emotion full of
character the other side remain full of
rational arguments and arithmetic and
numbers and the emotional argument
prevailed and you need all of those
elements in a really persuasive argument
and Trump is is very effective I agree
he's extremely good at what he does he
seems to me when when I watch him he's
very much like a standard stand-up
comedian in that he's a disruptive force
there is a status quo he comes in and he
disrupts it and he plays it how much
responsibility do you think Trump needs
to take for his word so it's drain the
swamp you know the American Dream is
dead to this you know to a sense of
crisis that we seem to have in America
well I think he does but I don't think
he will
I mean I think you know he can't be
absolved of the usual rules he did say
those things he just say some terrible
things he says them repeatedly and he
has got the knack of appearing
spontaneous but it's not wholly
spontaneous it's choreographed and it's
planned and during the election campaign
he was very disciplined when he went to
Michigan and Ohio old Rose Belt states
he gave a very disciplined speech about
how those people had been cheated by
globalization so his messages are pretty
clear and they're pretty thought through
he's not just shooting from the hip you
know he has a script you know he might
seem like it's like Billy Connolly you
know away he goes but it's all there
there's a sort of there's a threat and
Trump is like that too so yeah I think
he does
to take responsibility and it's up to
other politicians to make him take
responsibility not just the Democrat
Party but also the Republicans so I'd
blame lots of the people in the
Republican Party for letting this man be
there can do it they should they knew
what he was like they saw and that
gettysburg speech I quoted they saw
exactly what he was like they knew what
he was going to do
they knew that his whole appeal was to
escalate the culture wars and they knew
that that would make politics even less
pleasant than it was already hard it's
hard to imagine isn't it
yeah but you know I was thinking on the
on the flip side of it a person who I
respect who I thought was incredibly
eloquent who I thought was incredibly
articulate inspiring was Barack Obama
and I also feel like he got away with a
lot of things because he was articulate
and eloquent a lot of things that you
say Trump was doing them we would be
outraged and we are in fact he's doing
many of the same things that Obama did
in terms of immigration
he's Barack Obama was way worse in terms
of foreign policy in terms of bombing
other countries etc right but he seemed
to get away with a lot more because he
was this kind of statesman like figure
yeah Obama was definitely that the the
best speaker in my political lifetime
you just just look at what how he did in
what you what he was able to do with
words he was extraordinary I mean he
came from really nowhere and he won the
presidency because he was so so good at
his best - he's very moving
so there's but there's something about
Obama which makes him good which no one
else has got and it's not the the
crafting of the words we can all anyone
who's good can do that it's the fact
that behind Barack Obama lies a story I
have lost count over the number of last
year's of the number of politicians have
come to me and said can you make me a
bit like Barack Obama let me count the
ways which he would not like Barack
Obama I love it what he's not Barrack
Obama - he's not present to the United
States which gives you the certain
license to be grand in a way even Prime
Minister the UK it doesn't but three
most important of all you're not a black
man if his President of the United
States in when there's people who live
in that country still remember said
gated cities now that is a story he has
behind him the legacy of civil rights
and that is very best like the speech he
did on the night of his first election
victory in Grand Park in Chicago where
he talks about a hundred and two year
old woman in Alabama coming to the
polling booth to vote for the first time
for a black candidate to be president
United States he's using her as a
metaphor for the progress of the country
and it's incredibly moving and if anyone
else said that for us it just wouldn't
you know if if you're on just after
lunch at the local government Chronicle
conference talking about Housing Benefit
that's not gonna work you can't do that
kind of thing so he has a grandeur Obama
that other people simply can't have and
that gives him a lot that's the ethos
that's the character he's got and that
that's more important in writing
brilliantly
than anything else it's not the writing
so much as the setting the moment I give
you another classic example the really
great example Churchill who in the war
time becomes a great you know mobilize
the English language as said of him but
if you go back to 1899 Churchill's 24
years of age he's a candidate of the
Liberal Party in Old Northwest and he
stands up in a church hall insists on a
podium throughout seven people that and
he's talking about food rations and he
says never before in the history of
Oldham if so many people had so much to
eat and there's a sort of incredibly
lavish rhetoric then eight years later
he's a junior minister and the colonial
departments in Africa and he's standing
around a hole in the ground at the
opening of an irrigation scheme there's
about seven dignitaries in this vast
expanse so you could imagine acoustic
sound great
and he again he insists on a podium and
he says never before in the history of
Africa have so much water been held up
by so little masonry rubbish 19:40
suddenly in House of Commons never
before in the field of human history has
so much been owned by so many to so few
exactly the same construction exactly
the same rhetorical flourish but all of
a sudden the country's in peril we might
be about to be invaded it
seems to fit the idea of decorum is a
rhetorical term comes from Cicero and
it's decorous it fits the moment whereas
before he's talking at a level of
elevation which is too big for an
irrigation scheme and people get there
when people get things wrong in rhetoric
they're doing that they're going far too
high for the moments you've got to hit
the moment you've got to be appropriate
to your audience to your time and if
your audience is a bit flat and your
subjects a bit boring but you you don't
have to be boring but you have to be
plain you can't go too high and lots of
inexperienced writers
reach for purple prose cement this is
one of my place lines don't work as well
as I think no because the what
Constantine is trying to ask is can you
turn him into when it comes to speech
writing how important so it's a lot like
stand-up comedy and I think it was a
very good British comedian Russell Kane
said said I'm comedy about ten percent
of what you say 90 percent is delivery
would you agree with that when it comes
to speech right with speech writing
political erasure
I would yeah I mean the money is he was
one of the greats of speech writings
that said there are three things that
you need for a great speech delivery
delivery delivery I think that's largely
true yeah I think they all of that stuff
about character and ethos and emotion
largely comes across through through
delivery and the task of the writer is
to write in with the grain of that and
so is to is to provide that character
sketch so that you don't you don't get
this dissonance between the words that
you're saying and the character that
you've already established so delivery
is crucially important and not many
people can do it one of the tasks I
always give people when I was trying to
get them to be better is to watch
yourself with a sound earth down so
watch yourself back but turn the sound
down and what do we get what you get is
loads of character well you get a lot of
information different people just when
we were wandering around or standing at
a podium and so we've already got a
character Gordon Brown was a good
example because he gave you weight
gravity without doing anything you just
had that in his meat
his demeanor and but what he would do is
write in a weighty
grave way and that was too much so it
just felt like incredibly serious and
just way too much what he should have
done is lighten it a little bit in the
writing with a little bit of poetry for
example because it would have been
authentic because he did read poetry and
it was believable was you've got to make
sure that you're writing a believable
way I learned this by erroneous right
for John Prescott quite a bit no you
sure get told then go to try to help him
out and it's really my fault rather than
his but I found this story which is a
standard speech writers opening story
it's probably apocryphal but it works
really well and it's allegedly about dr.
Johnson and Boswell in the house in
Johnson's house in Goff square just off
Fleet Street and incredibly narrow
streets and you can the someone who's in
this side of the street and Lena can
lean out the window and reach someone on
that side of the street and Johnston is
alleged to have seen two women leaning
out of their windows respective sides of
the street hitting each other with
sticks and he's turned to Boswell
he said those two women will never agree
because they're arguing from different
premises nice little setup for a speech
about different promises so Prescott
does the set up really nicely tells the
story and then he hits the audience with
the punchline those two women will never
agree because arguing from different
buildings this doesn't make any sense at
all he has no metaphorical impact at all
it's just a rubbish story at the
beginning of a speech about something
else and I realize that was my fault
because it even if he had told it
correctly and got the play on words
that's not the sort of thing he would
say yeah
yeah that was an obvious insertion by a
clever clever speechwriter it's a bad
writing because I wasn't writing in
character so you've got to keep writing
in character so it is like writing in a
sense it's like writing a character in a
play where you know your character has
to try them unfold but not depart from
what we expect of them more is
reasonable for them to say and if a
speech writer writes a tough line which
we
you know as cuckoos right as we have all
written Duff lines my favorite example
of a Duff lining you would probably know
that is a Ian Duncan Smith when he was
leader of the Conservative Party and do
you remember the line yeah this is the
quiet man it's turning all um-- yes yes
whose fault is that
was it the delivery is it the
speechwriter is it a bit of both it's a
bit of both it's a bit of both in that
one I can see what they're trying to do
because they've been called that you
know hopeless and they were trying to
counteract they were trying to name the
central weakness and take it on and then
counteract it so I can see the thought
process and I mean I can see it's not a
great line you know could have been a
lot better but the delivery is truly
shocking isn't it drew few remember it
that quiet man is turning up the volume
you know he just shouts at random is
really really terrible
I think if he'd been in a sense if he'd
been very good at delivering it he
wouldn't have needed the line because
the line was there was a concession that
he was rubbish so if he hadn't been
rubbish he would have needed to do it so
in a way he was bound to get it wrong
because he was so awful another good
example of someone who wasn't awful but
was terrible as a speaker was mrs.
Thatcher so I mean she was very
effective but she was she was hot and
she notoriously had no real sense of
humor and she was given a lot of
surprise yes she was given a line by one
of her speech writers and it was it was
meant to mock the Liberal Party at the
time and they just got on this new logo
which looked like a dead parrot I said
they just used it was lame even then to
use a dead parrot sketch but they did
they gave her the dead parrot sketch to
deliver some what the Liberal Democrats
and she dutifully trotted through it you
can imagine how bad this is he should
look it up because it's really
shockingly awful Margaret Thatcher doing
the job please pass hidden who the dead
parrot sketch and she see obviously
throughout the whole rehearsal process
she had no idea why this was funny she
kept asking people is this funny will
people laugh and they say yes Prime
Minister it's funny and at the end of it
she did it and everyone laughed and she
had no idea why they laughed and she
came off and she said to John
Whittingdale who's a chief of staff at
the time she said to this Monty Python
chap is he one of ours
she just had no understanding of what
she was saying and yeah and yet she's
still managed to pull it off and they
realize they judge their audience
correctly I suppose she's just about
managed it yeah it's interesting you're
talking about quite a lot of leaders and
I was curious one of the things I always
find curious is I don't if you'll agree
with me but there is this idea that we
we strive towards an alpha male kind of
figure even if it's a female alpha alpha
in general Romania in what do you think
about that is projecting that sense of
strength and power and authority and
essential quality of being a leader it's
important yeah I mean we often pretend
we don't want that anymore and then when
we find we haven't got it we think oh
why aren't they strong
I mean Theresa may remember when she was
briefly the most popular prime minister
in the opinion polls there had ever been
really yeah that did happen the first
three months of treason were his
Premiership poll ratings were higher
than anyone has ever been before so I'm
triggered when people said at the time
it's so refreshing to have someone who's
authentic after David Cameron it was all
that you know Sabean etc exactly the
same thing happened with Blair to brown
it's really refreshing we've got someone
who's really himself at all and then
after a while you think yeah but these
people don't know what they want they
don't know what they're for and we turn
on them so I think that we're a bit
hypocritical about this we say off and
we want that but we don't really the
other thing we say of leaders too is we
want them to be conviction politicians
and we don't really we did what we mean
by that is we want them to believe what
we believe Blair was a very good example
because Blair in his early years from 97
onwards when he was immensely popular
179 seat majority poll ratings through
the sky he didn't really know what he
wanted to do he came to office and
wasted quite a lot of time because he
didn't quite have a plan for anything he
didn't know what he wanted to do with
health or education yet loads of scope
but he didn't really know what he wanted
to do later on in foreign policy had no
views at all later on in his Premiership
of course he's acquired
really strong convictions and everybody
hates them so it's not really true that
when you are clear and you've got strong
convictions everyone therefore likes you
they might respect you
in a regretful way but they don't
necessarily follow you so politics is a
weird business because you've got to try
and win people over I don't agree so for
example if I'm trying to win office
rather than win notoriety by someone
like Nigel Farraj and I want the votes
of you too and but you think one thing
you think the other I could say
absolutely categorically I agree with
you and that's fine
I got your vote but I'm where yours what
it's more tempting for me to do is to
find some rhetorical construct that
makes you think I'm kind of with you but
you think the same so that leads me to a
level of vagueness and which is
inevitable and obviously over time you
find out you discover that in the end
when it comes to policy and action I
have to take your line or your life and
at that point one of you will feel
disappointed or perhaps both of you
because I won't do it well enough for
you and I won't do it at all for you so
that's what happens that's the process
and that's why politicians are vague and
murky it's not because they are vague
murky people or they're bad people it's
because the structure of politics leads
you in argument to try and win the the
highest common denominator a counter
example that is somewhat Farraj who
precisely because he's only interested
in a small section of the population can
be as clear as he likes so he knows very
well that he is never going to track my
vote that I hate everything he stands
for but that's his calling card
he doesn't want to win pomme see
economists in The Times he wants to
parade Pomp's economists in The Times as
exactly the sort of London liberal
elites who hates him so he can be
healthful ever about the EU and our
immigration because his base which could
be up to 30% of the people at its height
will go for that he's got no chance of
getting to 40% when you're in election
winning territory but he's not trying to
so it's a lot easier to be clear when
you don't want a wide range and that I
think is the key to why speeches are not
as good as they used to be and it's not
the dilemma that Colburn is facing now
because before he was hard left he was
that you know Pro brexit anti-eu and all
of a sudden he's now got his desire and
he's a leader of the party
to say he's a man of principle sorry
he's Jewish
it is this problem yes it is it is his
problem he is Jeremy Corbyn has gone
into politics for the first time in his
career he's been in protests for such a
long time now all of a sudden he's
landed with this horrible job that he
never wanted of leading the Labour Party
which means he's got to make that kind
of appeal across the lines and he's
getting this trouble because of the
things he genuinely believes you know I
left the Labour Party because I believe
that topple a party to be anti-semitic I
just do I think it's indefensible but
they do have probably gave a more
generous account to what they think on
foreign policy they do have strong view
about imperialism and capitalism and
that's what they think but that's not a
winning proposition if you're looking to
expand beyond the left to people who
voted Tory last time in order for Jeremy
Corbyn to become Prime Minister people
who voted conservative in only a couple
of years ago
well after vote Labour now so he had
then asked to construct an argument that
not only keeps his own tribe faithful
but also wins those people over that's
really difficult and as he said in your
question he he's won his sense of
authenticity by not doing that kind of
thing he's a man of principle he
believes what he believes and in the
campaign to be in labour leader he was
by far the best person were better than
Andy Burnham and Liz Kendall and whoever
else it was because he did have
something to say I didn't agree with him
but I could see he was clearly the guy
he was telling you the truth as he saw
it the others were all over the place
with their triangulation and their
vagueness but it's really hard to
maintain that when once you try and
expand the coalition and so he is
finding that really difficult and on
Europe he's found it very difficult to
you so you're saying and this is my an
add on to this question you're saying
politicians it's all about being murky
you know not really committing but in
the energy breaks it can they really do
that anymore where you have a simple
binary question yeah I think they can't
I think they can't do it anymore and I
think the transition of politics from
class politics the culture war politics
is making that kind of old rhetorical
style redundant so I think they can't do
it and I think you're finding about the
Labour Party's found that
prosit where I've got some sympathy with
Jeremy Corbett's position actually
because he has his position has been
though we're remained party we lost the
argument we lost the boat and therefore
we should respect the burden carried out
and that's calculated to some extent
because lots of Labor voters were well
leave but it's not an ignoble position
and I've defended them against lots of
the critics but when you test that in an
election by the European elections it's
never going to work because it's like
the cancer part what I said before if
you're a very strong remain vote so you
suddenly think this guy's not on my side
if you're a really strong leave vote to
you well you're going to go to Farraj
instead so you're caught not quite being
one or the other and although it's going
to attempt to make a sophisticated
position this is not a sophisticated
argument and it needs to be black or
white and weirdly Jeremy Corbyn who's
always been a black and white politician
is now the sort of Blair right face in
courts in the middle it's gone full
circle yeah we've got some very exciting
news Emily Constantine yes we do I will
be doing my extremely well reviewed and
popularly enjoyed show called all well
that ends well which I did at Edinburgh
Fringe here in London at the Bill Murray
comedy club which is an angel in his
Lincoln on the 16th of November which is
a Saturday at 5:30 and I thought I'd try
and create a contrast between good
comedy and bad comedy so I've invited
Francis to emcee it as well absolutely
now because he's invited me we've sold
some tickets for the show we are also
gonna need more of you to come and
support comedy and support comedy know
there will support me I am comedy and
support Constantine as he delivers his
lecture - no I'm joking
come and watch a show it's going to be
brilliant it's going to feature me at
the top doing a little bit of ten
minutes of banter calling people fat
pricks and then we're going to bring
Constantine on
yeah we like hypocrisy so it's gonna be
absolutely awesome it's going to be in
London it's gonna be at the Bill Murray
pub at 5:30 p.m. that Saturday the 16th
of November we'll see you there
I didn't expect the entry to go this way
but you mentioned I didn't know this
that you'd left the Labour Party because
of of their allegations of anti-semitism
I am someone who's I'm very wary now
because the labels of racists gets
thrown around so much I don't even
awesome Attica Lee believe it you know
when people call someone racist I'm like
well I don't know are they are they not
but you obviously someone who's been
inside the party so tell us you know
what I what are the reasons that you
left what are some of the evidence for
these allegations well well I don't
think Jeremy Corbyn sits there thinking
I'm an anti-semite I'm now going to do
anti-semitic things I don't think that
so I don't think in that sort of
conscious proud racism the Jews yeah I
don't think any of that I think his he
ends up being an anti-semite out of a
series of other convictions so he
believes that imperialism is the most
important and potent force in world
politics he believes that America is a
driving force of that imperialism and he
believes an American capitalism as a
beneficiary of its conquests around the
world
the most notable Imperial state in that
analysis is Israel because it's caught
in the midst of a whole series of others
and it is a pressing man it's the
poppies of America and he's is that set
of convictions plus an exaggerated sense
that this is the most important thing of
all human history leads him to a
position of such hostility to what he
would call Zionism that he is then blind
to what is over 70 Semitism so if you
look at the mural on the wall for
example he didn't see anything wrong
anyone else would see it straight away
sorry could you just describe that a
little bit the mural is America as a
mural a mural was painted on a wall in
East London with a whole series of very
blatant anti-semitic caricatures on it
or moneylenders and usury and it was all
implying that the the Jews it was
implying a world Rothschild type Jewish
financial conspiracy and it was as clear
as day that that's
was being depicted Jeremy Corbyn shared
that mural a picture that mural on that
Facebook group didn't really notice it
and so I think he's be becomes blind to
those things he also because of that he
licenses the entry into the Labor Party
are people who really are overt overtly
anti-semitic so the there's always been
a very small minority of people on the
hard left who are anti-semitic there
always has been I mean I don't mean to
imply by that there aren't some terrible
racists on the right of course there's
powder and no different types but I hate
accusers a bipartisan right now the
conservative artists problem is more
with Islam yes with Islam than it is
with with Judaism but you know we're not
choosing which we which is the best
racism I think they're both quite bad
but the one that which which I could
because I was a member of they were
parties one is particularly personal to
me and so those people those vertice
mites are now members of the Labour
Party where's once upon a time they
weren't and so I think the the party has
been really infected with this and the
response to it has been very very slow
and I just felt I don't have it's not
once and for all thing I can rejoin the
Labour Party if and when this is
eradicated as a problem but I thought I
don't want to be a member of it whilst
this is they're not being taken
seriously though so I don't mean to make
you a fanfare of it but I just think
there we are no it's just I really
wanted to ask you about it because it's
something that we keep hearing about but
I'd never heard any more some somewhere
up quite so succinctly and kind of
explain what the allegations are what's
the substance because I think it's quite
important to be as generous to the
people your person as you can you know
work because I don't think it's as I
said before I'm not accusing Jeremy
Corbyn of being a racist so that was
ridiculous so I think everything I've
said is compatible with his claim that
he's an anti-racist campaigner and of
course he is in one sense and spent his
life protesting against various
oppressions and in justices and I I
don't I don't want to wash away that
record but I just think he has a blind
spot here where his various
causes clash and ends up in a position
which i think is really dreadful and I
don't want to be a member of a party
which has that feeling so this the it's
a hard left sensibility which I just
don't want to be part of the Labour
Party but it is they are the governing
force in the labour party and you can
either choose to stay there and try and
win it back and engage in that fight
it's not my fight anymore because I'm
not active in politics and I thought
actually better off just to to have the
freedom to criticise by coming out and
then that can be honest about it you're
outside the tent and outside it's a
great thing I'm glad we talked about
that because there's something that
doesn't get talked about good with that
clarity enough I think guys we wanted to
tell you we're very excited to say we've
got a new sponsor which is hello fresh
indeed we have hello fresh is a UK's
leading recipe box service delivering
fresh pre-portioned ingredients and
step-by-step recipes to your door it is
the easy convenient way to cook
delicious dinners from scratch every
single time choose your favorites from
19 recipes every week they have a whole
range of options there for you including
recipes that are ready in under 20
minutes there's family favorites there's
British cuisine there's world cuisine
hello fresher offering trigonometry fans
60 pounds of four boxes to take
advantage of that go to hello fresh coda
UK enter our special code which is of
course trigonometry and enjoyed
delicious dinners without any of the
drama the fresh ingredients come direct
from suppliers i they've been picked by
Constantine's family you can tell
Francis studied geography at a British
School because he can't tell the
difference between Russia and Romania
doesn't matter mate same thing breaks it
means breaks it and the great thing is
it's been proportioned for you so
there's no food waste
just like in my home country of
Venezuela the great thing we've had
fresh is that you're going to be able to
choose from 19 different recipes every
week so there is something for everybody
you're going to be
to eat with you kids it's going to be no
fuss dinnertime it's gonna be solved
yeah I really like the rapid box which
allows you to cook things in under under
20 minutes but the great thing about
hellofresh as well is it actually allows
you to open up your cooking range so
most households on average have about
six recipes that they cook regularly
hellofresh has up to 19 so you can kind
of expand a little bit in terms of your
cooking and of course they also don't
have a fixed subscription so there's no
term you can cancel you can skip weeks
you can change the size of the box you
can change the delivery address you can
do all kinds of stuff to suit your life
to enjoy delicious moment head over to
hellofresh code UK choose your box
choose your delivery slot and add your
favorite recipes discover the easy way
to get delicious dinners from scratch
and if you do that you'll get sick abs
just like me hello fresh we're offering
trigonometry fans 60 pounds off four
boxes to take advantage of that go to
hello fresh coda UK enter our special
code which is of course trigonometry and
enjoyed delicious dinners without any of
the drama we're coming back to
leadership who do you see on the horizon
who you think has the the rhetorical
skills perhaps to convince you know
there's some interesting candidates in
America on on the Democratic side
obviously who I'm curious about tulsi
gabbard
and Andrew yang are the people who are
bringing its total e different offering
do you think those two people may have
the the rhetorical skill to go with
their ideas yeah I think they're
interesting I think they do they do I'll
doing something different and the
Democratic Party needs to do something
different because it's just tried the
old conventional form with Hillary
Clinton that's why they go for Joe Biden
might have beaten Trump actually yeah
because Joe Biden was very very strong
in the places where Trump won the
election I mean Trump won the election
very very narrowly and he won in places
where with Lutins unfortunate lives sewn
up in Michigan the old industrial
heartland that's Joe Biden's patch
that's where he that's who
so I think he might well have one in
those places and if you win there you
win so I think he might have beaten
Trump though I don't think he'd be the
great can let for next time because I
think politics is so different now and
Hillary Clinton was the last of the
really conventional Democrat candidates
I mean at a time when the big issue is
the elites versus the people what used
to put up what a Clintons you know it's
just a terrible terrible candidate I
mean I think she'd have been quite a
good president because she administra be
really smart and all of that but as a
candor and she was really really bad and
I think they do need to do something
different they might go to the left you
know they might have him might do what
Labour Party is done they might go for
Bernie Sanders still they might be fair
Elizabeth Warren just somewhere but my
Elizabeth Warren's a much more polished
kind of performer but next time that you
know Cassio got this she's not old
enough yet because there's a age
threshold for the American president do
you have to be 35 years of age and she
won't be 35 in time so she can't yet be
akela I mean clearly in time if she she
manages to keep her elevation up she's
very effective I mean there's someone
using social media and coming to your
attention in a really clever way not at
all
clunky and that's part of rhetoric now
it's getting across in different ways
but with her I feel she's like the left
wing Trump in a way do you know what I
mean the way she is where she is I mean
the way she is she's not see if we see
if she can make a transition because her
job at the moment is simply to critique
and criticize but that's fair enough
because that is your job in opposition
and she's really good at it he's very
effective she's clear you know when she
speaks she's very good she could
creating a good Hartman sometimes are
are a bit cheap but again that's part of
politics no need to criticize people too
much for that I mean part of your job is
to get attention and to put your
opponents on the spot and so she she's
very good at that whether she can now
make a transition to being a bigger
figure who can then make positive cases
for things we'll see I wouldn't say she
can't because she's clearly talented but
some of the other candidates are you
know Harris is interesting I am Not sure
I've seen yet the person who is quite on
the measure of Trump in that
I'm gonna show any of them happen I'm
not sure they have either and Trump is
changing the rules and I think they're
spooked by them I think they don't quite
know how to approach him there's a very
interesting argument about what
strategies you would deploy to try and
take on Trump do you do you go really
serious and try and shame him or do you
mock him or do you have someone who's a
real Patriot do you get an ex or veteran
to be the Democratic candidate and and
make him seem unamerican what's the best
way of doing it do you get someone from
his heartland who then represents
authentic American values of the old
industrial north who can then move out
from there it's it's a big argument
within the Democratic Party about what
they need and I'm not sure the answer
because Trump really does pose a problem
that kind we've not seen before and I
develop democracy well one of one of the
things that Donald Trump is famous for
is you talk about mocking he is what
Scott Adams I think cause linguistic
kill shots incredible I mean as if you
have you know abstract yourself from
whether you agree with him or not he's
incredibly effective at caricaturing the
person he's talking about in you know
two words absolutely destructive
combination and that was a Rubio you
know release applaud that was Jeb Bush
low-energy jab yeah lying Ted Cruz all
this stuff like crooked hill and there's
a visual component to it that's a curry
you can if you look at Hillary she kind
of does look a bit crooked and then it
all kind of glues together yes into the
sink so the mocking I don't think it's
gonna work he's gonna blow anyone out of
the comes after him the visual elements
really important because you know
painting pictures is what you're trying
to do that that's what works far better
in any speech than any long argument if
you can paint somebody a picture then
that's just going to last we know that
that sticks in the memory longer Trump
is good at it but other people can be
good at it
there's no reason why you can't come
back I mean God is giving you enough in
materialism you know it's like it's not
that hard to come back at Trump and
fight fire with fire it's a question
whether that's the right thing to do
because you might be right there he has
got the command of that and he's
fearless he will say stuff
you won't say so you've got the internal
filter you think actually that's beyond
the rules of ordinary civilized
conversation I'm not going to call him
that here even though it's just pops
into my head was he'll just say it you
know the most remarkable moments in all
of political history I think is when
Trump started mocking disabled people
I'm not going to do it because it was
like the playground in the 1970s and
Manchester where people would do you
know Joey Deakin jokes and Trump I
thought we were better than that now but
we're not there was a debate about it
wasn't that that whether he intended to
do it or whether there was something
there was and and typically he he
started to climb down and then basically
thought that and so he didn't deny it
I mean he in due course he said he
didn't really mean to do it but you just
look at him you know it was pretty
obvious what he was doing and his
attacks on Hillary Clinton were way
beyond what you'd expect in the normal
course of politics I mean politics
always been pretty raucous I don't wants
to be too pious about it go back to 1800
and Thomas Jefferson and John Adams and
Adams accuses Jefferson of fathering a
child with his slaves which he had and
Jefferson in response accuses Adams of
being pro-british he imaginary more
brilliant insult than that in throw
British just after the Revolutionary
Wars and it was really really
acrimonious and they hated each other so
it's not as though it's always been
sweetness and light but still there was
a sort of rules of decorum that people
observed which Trump just doesn't he's
like that the nutter you look into his
eyes he'll do anything he's frightened
of him a bit and you think that what
you've just said we've now reached a new
low well every time I think we've every
time we set the bar he buys us tonight
I can sort of bellydancer get underneath
it so I hesitate to say we've reached a
new low I fear we're heading that way in
this country there I fear that the early
tactics of the Johnson campaign are
mimicking some of trumps and stuff I
mean Johnson is close to Steve Bannon
and I can see already some of their
tactics being flirted with
so for example at the Johnson launch
event they had some of his supporters
booing a question by a journalist that
wasn't a great question but he'd never
do that you'd never do that but they did
yeah you're getting people turning up on
television shows with choreographed
ambush attacks on on the positions that
journalists have taken just sort of
pre-planned aggression just to up the
stakes they're starting to flirt with
some of that stuff is the way they
controlled the press conference it's
really quite clearly banning like and I
just really hope they don't head that
way well that's why I mentioned David
Lammy early because I feel like
everyone's doing it now everybody's got
basically an illegal move that they're
coming to pull it's the inevitable and
understandable response when one side
goes rogue is you go rogue back you head
them back and it's exactly I've had this
feeling last few days I think why don't
the other candidates bring out loads of
dirt on Boris Johnson tell the truth
about it why don't they just as loads of
things like I know which I won't say
even here by oh come on oh come on why
are they not using it why not going
because I'm anything there's only going
on the Internet well the reason my word
the reason I won't is because actually
you have to stop yourself from that is
another escalation then you go up there
and then they come back complete
obligation to the set a good example
because it just escalates and then you
know you hit each of them this is what's
happening in America where the Congress
has been the most partisan in Congress
the last two sessions of Congress been
the most partisan in the history of
America the American Republic because
there's no collaboration and cooperation
between the two parties now and in a
split Constitution if they don't
cooperate it doesn't work but they're
not cooperating because they're in these
tribal blocks now
and the Democrats say why should we
cooperate with this really right-wing
nasty Republican party so we're going to
just behave like they do which is
understandable but then it's completely
locked and the Republicans then say are
the Democrats is impossible we can't get
anything through because of these
lunatics no you're the loo it just
becomes childish and there's a real risk
we do that
Briggs is doing that to us we're doing
that it breaks it well we're recording
this as you said just at the time of the
conservative leadership election by the
time it goes out we will see if the
tactics have worked for Boris I defend
with Boris's though it's like it's hard
to get stuff to stick to him because
everyone just thinks he's an idiot
anyway you do yeah they do think it's
sort of priced in they think well it's
become a character hasn't it ya know
what's happened that's what it is
he does have a character the very fact
that you called him Boris that I'd like
to go back and once again where you call
him Johnson it's very important that
opponents of his destruct the idea that
he's Boris no one else is Jeremy or
Michael you know you don't talk about
you know the others but you have a
relationship with this Boris character
which you've just described by use of
that word and that's a real gift for a
politician when if he's managed to do
that and it's part of the rhetorical
task in deconstructing him is to take
that apart and treat him as a try and
treat him as a serious politician so
exactly for that reason Boris you've
you've priced in all of these personals
transcription aggressions and these
patooties things which make him
unsuitable to be a prime minister
you've just in a way said oh well that's
just Boris that's what Boris's that's a
character of Boris let's not worry about
it
and if you're an opponent of is you need
to take that apart and going touching on
comedy in speech writing but using Boris
Boris Johnson as an example he is
created what I see is a comedian as a
comic persona the bumbling English tough
who wanders from you know crisis to
crisis putting his foot in it yeah you
know all the rest of it yes yeah it's a
little bit Jeeves he's exactly that it's
a little bit Woodhouse and it's really
interesting weather how it translates
I've always thought that that persona
precisely because it is bumbling and
it's not very effective
the whole joke is you're a bit hopeless
will is not a very good persona to take
you all the way because when you're
actually then at an international summit
doing really boring but important work
I'm not sure we want the clown and I'm
not sure it works at that point but he
does have that and you saw and if you
saw his launch speech but you had a very
uneasy juxtaposition of that comic
persona with a load of really quite
boring serious stuff it's quite
difficult to do the transition from one
to the other so to have a bumbling
persona and get your comedy out of it
and then go serious is really hard you
could there is a character you could do
a course which lots of comedians have
which is that the the comedy comes from
the serious subjects and you're quite
grave and pious and earnest but you're
funny you can do that and lots of people
do it and at some point in Johnson's
career he should have chosen to make
that kind of transition could keep the
comedy keeping funny because I did used
to find him funny he is you know he is a
personally witty person who's capable of
seeing a joke and delivering it so he he
is bright and and funny much more so
than most politicians but I find I found
that his comedy really great I find it
annoying ëifí I see the construction of
the character I'm beginning to see that
the lines of the joke and the that's the
crucial thing isn't it that you've got
to try and conceal the the construction
of it so it appears as though you've
just making this up off the top of your
head even though of course you haven't
my big moment as a speech writer was in
fact to joke that's why I made it by a
brilliant Les Dawson gag this is in 2006
link was Tony Blair's last conference to
the Labour Party he'd always announced
he was resigning and he had to go and
speak to them and the day before he
spoke Schreiber his wife had said
something really rude about Gordon Brown
she was caught by journalists calling
Gordon Brown a rude word and she denied
she said it but we knew she's probably
had because she definitely thought him
and it was it sounds incredibly trivial
about but it was all over the evening
news and it was all over the Foreign des
newspapers and Brown was furious because
he'd done a big speech which wasn't
being covered it shows how trivial we
are the rubbish show by shri Blair was
knocking out the Chancellor's speech but
it was he was absolutely furious so we
realized we had to deal
with this the following day in Blair's
speech and I thought the obvious way to
do that is to make a joke of it we're
going to make light of it and how can we
do that what what was Jo can we tell I
thought it's I just thought it's got the
elements of Music Hall here because it's
the the guy next door it's his wife
there's a sort of seaside postcard
vintage Music Hall elements of this so I
started looking up old Arthur Askey
jokes and you know max Miller and and I
found this Les Dawson gak which was my
wife's just run off for the guy next
door and you know what I'm really gonna
miss him I thought it's a little bit
vulgar for the prime minister but we
customized it and we wrote it up as he
made a full eulogy to his wife and they
said at least she won't run off with the
guy next door yeah I remember and we we
didn't put it in the script because we
didn't want the press to know that it
was there could we release the script
beforehand to the press but we left it
up to Blair to judge whether to say it
or not to judge whether it felt right
because we tried to clear with Brown he
didn't want him to say it and we just
left it to Blair to say and I've told
that story many times and I mean you'll
know better than I do when you trip over
the line you don't always get laughs
I've - and when on occasions I've told
the story and not delivered it properly
I don't quite get the laugh so for him
to deliver it at that moment judge
whether - he didn't have it with him he
had to remember it it was a Larry
last-minute thing and deliver it and he
did it perfectly and it just totally
brought the house down his room shows
the slow standards of comedy and pauses
here but he absolutely brought the house
down and the next day there were double
page spreads in the newspapers about
this joke and the book I got the joke
from was featured on Channel 4 News and
it just became a big thing and the
interesting thing about it I thought
later was that the joke of course the
reason jokes so good not because it's
such a fantastic joke is because it
concedes the point it's because it
contains in it the admission that she
did say it it's like yeah we know but it
doesn't matter that's what the joke said
it was the joke was part of the argument
it wasn't just a joke and the and that
made it
saying and it made it potent and then
laughter I think was partly the release
of people thought that's a tense moment
which you've just got rid of with it
with a joke
you've not stopped and said oh now
here's a joke we've we've said something
in the joke and concealing that plotline
in a gag is knows lots of playwrights do
you know you you when your guard is down
they sneak a point past you don't well
and that's what that's why I was trying
to do there on that brilliant note we
have to wrap up mainly because I want to
end the interview so you can tell us the
salacious detail the last question thank
you for it's been a brilliant interview
but the last question we always ask is
what is the one thing that we're not
talking about as a society that we
should be talking about well Morris
Johnson's privately well at any point if
you'd asked me that until recently I
would have said climate change because
that's all that has been the great issue
that we haven't talked about and it's
very interesting why no one's ever done
a great climate change speech which they
haven't yet but but maybe one day they
will so so now we are talking about that
happily the the big domestic question
we're not really talking about is is
housing and why kids are people of
thirty years of age now in good jobs
we'll probably never own their own home
because because it's so ridiculously
expensive and no one's got any clue how
to do that it involves a whole series of
difficult thing was like taxing wealth
and taxing property and taxing land
which sound incredibly left-wing but I'm
in favor of all of them and there are
facts old lloyd-george liberal ideas
that turn of the 19th century and we
need to do that we need to talk about
wealth taxes and land taxes it's a
difficult conversation to have because
lots of people lose out but that's the
conversation I think we need we can't
fix the housing market so we get really
really tough about it let's dig into
that a little bit because this is a
debate Francis and I often have because
I own property and he doesn't only
bought my first flat two years ago and
I'm in my mid-thirties so I know exactly
what you're talking about but what the
the way I've always seen it is neither
party of the two mainstream parties are
frankly any other
she can fix the housing bubble which is
essentially what we have does the super
high housing prices because the people
who own property have way too much
invested in the house prices being high
and they are the people who essentially
vote right that's right so so you're not
that's why we talk about right so my
point is you're basically gonna have to
say to every homeowner in the country
you're gonna lose 40 percent of your
assets
so the Frances here can get a flat and
that is frankly not worth I may know I
may not phrase it like that but you are
essentially right that is a brilliant
political predicament but that's what
leadership in politics is it's finding a
way to make that unpalatable argument
yeah so there will be losers from this
but I'd have to make the arguments about
equity about generational impact so yes
okay you are currently in a position
where you might lose out but in due
course or god take take me time I've
been a real beneficiary of from the
house price inflation in London but I
also have two children so what about
them am I not bothered that unless I
just gift them money they won't be able
to do that so you find a generational
argument for it and you also find a way
of mitigating the impact so it's not a
punitive thing I'm not trying to punish
you for having a house I'm trying to
spread the burden in a more just way so
I wouldn't you have wealth taxes in
order to make a a load of new revenue
and say what we need to do is just
smooth the taxes so we'll reduce income
tax so you can keep more of your money
but we'll transfer that tax on to things
like property which doesn't move and you
know it can hide it or land likewise
which would have the coral the
beneficial impact to of making housing
less volatile as an asset reduce the
prospects of a crash and reduce the
prospects of then austerity for the rest
of us so we're all complicit in this
bubble and we do need to prick it in an
orderly way but I'm not going to try and
punish you I want to I don't want to I
don't want you to pay any more tax than
you're paying today you can see your
skill coming thank you very much for
coming on the show tell everybody your
Twitter handles I should run list
at peak Hollins times perfect and by
Phillipsburg is a brilliant book as
always follow us at trigger pod on our
social media subscribe to the YouTube
channel click the bell button next to
subscribe button so you get notified as
you all know this is also available as a
podcast and we will see you next week
with another Brillon episode take care
good bye
[Music]